has been a winemaking region for over
3000 years
the phoenicians planted the first
grapevines in pre-roman times
the white palomino grape is the source
of sherry a fortified wine
from herith it's exported all over the
world
the andalusian city celebrates the end
of the grape harvest with a major
festival dedicated to the wine
to start off the festivities the grapes
are pressed by foot
for centuries this was the traditional
way to crush the grapes
for an entire week the city celebrates
the wine that made hereth
world famous sherry
my father worked in a wine cellar when i
was a little boy
i met him there after work i'll never
forget the scent of the bodega
this wine is everything to us i knew
that even as a child
my family owes a lot to the wine because
many of us were barrel makers
one of the local wineries that
cultivates this 3000 year old tradition
is the bodega luis perez
but the winery itself is a newcomer
founded just 12 years ago
luis pereth used to teach viticulture or
wine growing at university
now he puts his ideas into practice in
his own winery
he doesn't produce sherry though instead
he produces red wine which was
widespread in the region up until
200 years ago he's planted over 20 grape
varieties
the climate is ideal here and so is the
chalky soil
which does a good job of storing water
in this rather arid region
we know from past centuries that our
soil here is wonderfully suited to red
wine
varieties i'm very interested in culture
especially the development of wine
culture children and young people
nowadays don't know anything about that
anymore
that's why we hold grape tastings not
the usual wine tastings
the differences you taste in the wines
actually originate in the grapes
themselves
the grapes are harvested by hand and
processed immediately
the vineyard focuses on quality over
quantity
we have small plots of land whenever a
plot is ripe
we harvest it that same day we don't
wait
we harvest
has made it his mission to prove that
hadith can do more than just produce
sherry
it's wonderful i'm happy to take a
second taste though
but most visitors for the sherry
especially during the wine festival
in the traditional bodegas they even
have a chance to taste sherry that's
aged at least 30 years
this winery only produces a very old
cherry
the sherry keeps for long periods which
is why it was developed in the first
place
seafarers brought wine with them to sell
in america
but white wine has only 12 to 13 percent
alcohol
they fortified it to keep it from
spoiling on route
we learned how to distill from the arabs
sherry is also aged in a special way the
young wine stays in the top barrels
the older wine is transferred to the
bottom barrels
the bottles are filled from the lowest
layer then
more wine is poured in at the top there
are no vintages the quality is always
the same
you can't find one like this anywhere
else in the world
i'm a wine connoisseur so i want to
visit a variety of wine cellars
this one only produces aged sherry so
that's different
but it's always good to get to know
something new
sherry will be celebrated here in hedeth
through the end of the year
then in november another location will
be chosen to be next year's
european wine city